he said he said the ten people that get
chosen are gonna be on the Netflix show
is gonna be crazy he's gonna be blown up
you guys are all gonna be blown of his
she just promised the world your
mindsets bad you're not in this game
you're not gonna be successful and then
couple hours later on like nah [ __ ] that
I'm not signing this NDA rack up my
credit cards for adspend because these
people are gonna change my life I'm
still hopeful because I just invested
everything I have I'm in the studio
right now I just got off the phone with
Bogdan Kozlov he's this guy I found on
Instagram after he had just been scammed
by jet set fly Jet Set fly it's been all
over he ran this course called a 90 X
that turned out to not be all it was
cracked up to be and I got a rare window
into that world as it was going down and
I'm going to share it with you guys this
is so rare and special that we sort of
get a an inside look at a scam while
it's unraveling and we get to see the
inside pieces of it from someone
firsthand so I hope you guys enjoy this
very special edition of a fake guru I
will be minimally editing this because I
want the full story to be out there
please enjoy the talk and I'll see you
guys next time
welcome back to fake gurus today we're
with Bogdan Casas love I believe is how
you say your name right
awesome awesome so a little back story
before we just jump in this is a fake
that this guy has been scammed by a fake
guru who is operating now and everyone's
just realizing that it's not what they
thought it was and Bogdan sort of below
he sort of was one of the first guys to
blow the whistle on this guy so we're
gonna get the inside scoop this is a
rare inside scoop to the inner workings
of the mind of a fake guru brought to
you from the source itself and so we're
just gonna start Bogdan by just talking
about your mind state leading up to
everything and how you how he got you in
and then what made you what was the
first things that you made you realize
this guy isn't right right right almost
from the beginning before he even
announced he 9tx and uh you know selling
this specific program so you know I
found them on the Instagram through
friends I started following him and you
just see this flashy lifestyle that he's
living it captivates you and it makes
you want to be part of it and uh he
brings you in and you're like wow like
this guy he's crushing it he was 20 at
the time and he's hanging out with all
these people who are successful you know
he was posting pictures with a
millionaire mentor Jason stone Moscow
like all these people that are seemed
legit like the question is sort of if
you hang out with somebody that's legit
given the scenes legit guy this guy this
guy and then for a little while he
decides to release this emailing the X
program and I don't know if you saw his
Instagram stories and everything about
the e90 X before you deleted it did you
see that no you got a tell and and this
is sort of gonna serve morons like it
it's also a history we're capturing the
history of everything so treat me and
the audience like we don't know anything
tell us buddy not yet art so I mean I'll
see if I can get the stories for you
because we did end up saving them before
you deleted them be perfect in this
video but what he basically did was he
used must those results and he showed
his results on his phone how he did 800
K in like three months or something a
hundred fifteen thousand and thirty
billion and then he said where we're
coming out with this program evening the
X where we're taking ten people and then
they use ember venom guarantee to hit
100k in revenue we're asked to have at
least five thousand dollars for
advertising and taken from zero six
figures in ninety days pretty much
guarantee we're gonna give them $10,000
cash I don't believe what somebody says
guarantee you know that's what nobody
ever said guaranteed business so if
somebody says guarantee it's automatic
like he's gonna fulfill her yeah they
say the icing on the cake was that he
said if you don't hit 100k we're gonna
give you 10 K cash yeah talking - soon
and and if you don't make six figures
I'm really [ __ ] 10,000 lost cash so so
that caught everybody that's like all
right this is wrong yeah no losing
right so every beverage feels like I'm
all you know I was like ten people and
then he starts talking about a Netflix
show he says he said the ten people that
get chosen are gonna be on the Netflix
show it's gonna be crazy he's gonna be
blown up you guys are all gonna be blown
up he just promised the Pearl so I
decided I'm gonna start a real item
honey docu-series so I'm called the e90
X challenge II sent three commerce 90
cents for 90 days and six figures and XS
the X commerce which is the name of my
company in the name of my family my
family's my team these are my people for
life um so we're gonna start a show
we're gonna take ten people and we're
gonna say you know at least $5,000 in
advertising budget and take them from
zero to six meters in less than 90 days
where did this Netflix thing cover me
does he have any affiliation with
Netflix I don't think so at this point
now we're just hyped up yeah where I
felt me we're getting ready to invest
all this money and we just want to
believe everything we can about like
this has to be real yeah let me get let
me get personal for a second here
because I know you got to know some of
the ten people of the ten people who
ended up I don't know how many people
signed up did did you just have 10k
sitting around or was that hard for you
I'm sure that wasn't easy to just throw
inning for anyone to throw 10k well
first of all it wasn't ten people he
said it was ten people they ended up
taking every single person that applied
so they had about 50 people yeah 50
people and arranged anywhere from five
cakes 25k and nobody knew this everybody
what he said on these Instagram stories
was this is all you said you need at
least five K and had spent budget
massive at least $5,000 for advertising
and that's all you said so everybody's
thinking okay I need five K and you'll
never take us in um you know their sales
people were having us send personal
videos explaining our life situation
really making it seem like they were
picking people out and you got to be
special
everybody everybody thought like I got
the call that that holy [ __ ] I'm about
to be on Netflix my life is about to
change me and only ten people got
selected out of the
and thousands of people turns out they
took anybody who had the money you know
this is sinister this is messed up
insane
and going back to your question no I did
not have the money oh I actually knew my
life just flipped upside down about a
year ago
I was in the fire department and that
was my dream job you know making 100k
here starting basically but over time
and I got jammed up I was at a bar guy
decides to attack me I decide to fight
back and I end up losing my job for it
you know so so I was in the point in my
life where I'm like I need to change my
life around I need to work for myself I
need to make sure this would never
happen again
so for me to get that money I was
actually doing a little bit of econ
before not really pushing it but I ended
up having to sell one of my stores I got
5k for it is a highly 15k revenue I had
to use my tax return and then I had to
tap into my savings so I only had like a
thousand left in my bank account because
I was the hole and I believe these
people are going to change my life you
know I'll use credit cards I'll rack up
my credit cards for ad spend
because these people are gonna change my
life these guys tapped you out I mean
they were like yeah well we explain the
payment process because I know there was
something kind of weird there the
project was weird
right absolutely this is the sketchiest
part and my brother told me to say thing
he's like my brother my mom everybody
was like this is very sketchy that
they're doing this so I said can I pay
in the credit card they say no they say
we only take cash
wire or quick pay all things that you
can dispute the King charge back so
there's no get your money back but we
were all just sold the dream there's
people that flew out from across lake
from Texas to California just to give
them cash cuz they're like I'm gonna be
locked in I want to make sure somebody
doesn't take my spot I'll flied out
insane a guy on parole on house arrest
actually couldn't even leave the state
he drove over there gave the money and
drove back the same day he could've
let's jail for that
but you Wayne you wanted to change his
life you think I want you guys locked me
in make sure that you're not giving away
my spot crazy did anyone say like no
this is sketch that you know we can't
pay in cash I was thinking it and I kept
asking them their salespeople I was like
can I just put this on my credit card
doesn't honor now see the credit card
user for ads this way you'll make a lot
more money
I'm sorry okay and I really was naive
and foolish I was blinded by by the
dream well I mean you were in a bad spot
in your life you wanted to find a way
out and this guy comes and he dare he
looks like blaze looks legit
he's got all the insta clout all the
whatever and he promises you the world
and what I mean you you see a great
opportunity you seize it man that's
supposed to be the American dream
exactly this is a crazy story by the way
I can't believe this guy this unboxing
blows my mind I didn't know is it
illogical that is pathological okay so
so you get accepted you're super excited
then what happens you get you get to
what do you go somewhere all right so um
I sent the money and then they had to
have three of them we went to the three
event and when we're at the hem three of
them you know what the hem three of em
was that he hosted I don't know if you
heard about it now I don't know been in
Vegas he had a whole bunch of like
people on there was like bunch of heavy
hitters you know they had a hardcore
closer chase hero local Hatter all these
people that do business so we get there
were all hype I only mounted wonderful
people that worry maybe exit this one
we're still thinking like we're one out
of the ten people yeah he came up on
stage he starts talking and then he says
whatever wants to be part of unity X bla
bla bla as to what we're doing to go to
the back and you could sign up were like
wait a minute
I thought it was 10 people I was like
what like I can't believe this
so actually so he comes on stage and
he's talking about
EDX and he's like these are all the
coaches that are gonna be on there he
starts bringing a random people that
aren't even the coaches I actually have
a telegram chat with a bunch of people
and some of the people had three that
actually do really well on Shopify and
Amazon are in my chat and they said yeah
like he just bought us on station they
say anything and they started telling
people we're going to be the coach and
they're like we never agreed to be the
coach right then we just had to roll
with it because we didn't want to make
him look bad on stage you know so I mean
they
everybody goes home we're still not
really here and I did they give us
access to their XCOM courses which are
all about three or four years old
extremely outdated and half them videos
are missing so we're like and they call
it preseason training we're like this is
pretty ridiculous this stuff is like 4
or 5 years old none of this was really
gonna work so pretty useless well we
just had a road with it until they
finally decided that they wanted to
start so I don't put the exact date but
they end up saying okay we're having a
last-minute meeting and um where they
live Santa Ana California and they're
like whoa whoa love will reimburse your
flights in your hotels if you could come
here this weekend so I'm like [ __ ] like
this way like eco and I was in Ari I got
to do it if they're gonna reimburse I
got to do it I have to leave within like
45 minutes I booked a flight I just had
out there so then that was just a waste
of time going they gotta send a yacht
and they did absolutely nothing like you
go up you go to them and they act like
they don't even know you or they won't
even really want to talk to you like
they were so shady
they're only like friends which you
overlook friendly when they're in front
of people and they needed to look good
so they're like they're piping up
program on the top you know they're
talking but we're gonna give you these
products we're gonna tell you exactly
what to do how to run these pad sense
how to kill these ads it's basically
telling you that they can hold you to
100k men just to get you more confidence
or lagari cool that sounds good I'm all
about right that's over we go home and
then it's like another month or
something before they actually set on
the schedule p90x once they send out the
schedule for you maniac oh let's
backtrack before that when we got there
everybody already paid as soon as we got
there and how they want people to sign
contracts after we paid and they're
telling people there's no refunds
whoa okay you haven't signed a contract
and you pay exactly the receipt we have
a receipt right
does anybody have receipts at this point
no the only receipts we have screenshots
of either wire transfers or okay
okay all right I'm getting stressed out
just live here in this dude okay all
right all right so yeah yeah so when we
got to law California that's when they
had a signed contracts and did they let
you read the contracts do they let you
say anything back about it or what
honestly I think need to sign it I acted
like I signed out in the signing it
sounds like this is sketchy I'm not
signing this
so I didn't Beyonce but I was like if
not I'm not doing this cuz everything's
already at this point I'm very real it
was caught in the dream but at this
point I'm starting to get realistic
right and I'm like the alarm bells are
going on that you really chrysalis seem
it really off I'm still hopeful because
I just invested everything I have and
I'm praying this works but this is
sketchy I'm not signing this contract I
don't know what it says I don't care
what it says unless I am right everybody
everybody else signed it I end up not
signing it you know that event is over
go home it's like a month and a half
later or a month later they send us the
schedule of email X I'm looking at the
schedule and automatically I'm like what
the hell is this I'm worried this is
absolutely not what I signed up for
so we haven't even started they sent the
contract and I said no absolutely not so
I contact Shane Josh's business partner
his name is jet said Conrad and he's
supposed to be like he's like behind the
scenes running the show and I took him
on like a listen like the schedule you
sent this is not what we are we've
really agreed upon this is what I bought
into him can they get her pretty fun he
said did you have your first call you
mister no but this isn't what I bought
in so I didn't want to have my first
call he says well you bad you sign the
contract that there's no refunds
so so so what was in the contract that
you were like wait what and what is that
what is this what is this well the
contract basically didn't have anything
in there that they were promising either
all right so they were just saying we're
gonna teach you but they need to say
what they're gonna teach us or anything
like that I could get the contract and I
could give it to you after this yeah for
sure for sure sure so he goes he says
that's too bad
in the contract there's no refunds I
replied today or like couple hours later
what kind
crack and the next day she blocks me he
just ends up blocking me on telegram
something RI lately at this point this
is why I started revolting right so at
this point not by talking to people and
I'm like this is crazy what we bought
into this is [ __ ] like a curse I'm
sorry no no you're fine
hey what's that sound in the background
though there's like a little clicking
sound it's pouring in New York right now
see okay okay okay I wish I could stop
it but I can't no that's all right don't
don't sweat it dude doesn't sweat it
I'm just explaining it for the viewers
so they can just tune it out okay so
it's just pouring on dude edge when it
rains man it pours or this is going down
on you right now right so at this point
I'm like I'm like no like this is this
emotion I'm telling people this isn't
what we signed up for bah bah bah and uh
at this point I have a group chat with
like three or four of us that I met at
and three at the event and I'm just
talking to them and they're all trying
to be like very positive about the whole
thing they're like listening just go
through with it we invested all this
money just continued above a blonde
they had their calm they like to call us
firebomb there's still light though
there's the hyped up on the dream and
not Maga right like I guess I just got
to continue I have no choice there's no
refunds I can't do anything about this I
just have to continue with with this
course I guess so we have um I think we
have our first coal but Musco I think it
was what must goes with somebody else
but it was just a call basically
explaining what we're gonna do and how
they're gonna do it okay cool
alright cuz they what they said in the
first call is like yeah we're gonna
teach you this and that nothing okay
cool I guess like maybe it'll be what
they promised but it wasn't it wasn't
well the big number is did they get you
to 100k right like that's the big did
they get anyone what were people hittin
hundred KS left and right that's the
promise that they gave you right we're
gonna get everyone to 100k we're gonna
teach you so much we're gonna hand
holding you all the way up to 100 km
sales about 30 base in half the people
in the program how to go and pay for
other mentors to help them because we
we're getting absolutely nothing
anytime we would message
one of the coaches they would say I'm
sorry but we can't respond
Josh house is on the contract and say we
can't respond to anybody and we can't
help you wait what why would Josh not
want you to be happy what that's so
weird
exactly even the head on he had a
coaching call with I guess some other
coaches that were never even supposed to
be in the program and while they were
doing their zoom my friend was recording
it and he had his messages popped up on
the side and then the messages we have
screenshots he's telling the person
that's doing the coaching call hey don't
answer the questions about their
products only talk about mindset and
then he goes ahead and says there's like
five people in here um he just starts
talking bad about a few people he's like
these people are just all they do is
complain they're [ __ ] or something
like that so we have all these
screenshots for Pro talk so it's like
this like psychological game he's
playing on and basically everybody so no
so so the highlight though is that
you're paying 10k for this course
there's no chargebacks it's catching
everybody when they're kind of you know
at a low point they're trying to make
money they're trying to get to get their
life right and then he promises you 10
100k in sales and at this point it's 30
days in out of what 60 days 90 days out
of 90 days and nobody's making money
everyone's going to other coaches cuz no
one no one's making any money with this
and he won't let anyone answer the calls
and stuff like this
do you remember what people's sales
numbers were at this point it's your own
at this point how do you mean think they
they taught us ads you know they even
teach people ads yet I think they might
have just got into how to build a store
but it wasn't like anything worth
$10,000 the calls I kept telling Josh I
was like this is all stuff I could find
on YouTube there's no way just pay ten
thousand dollars for a YouTube course
you know what have you been what have
you been talking about for 30 days what
hey what is he talking about with you
guys mine said he would he would he
would be like emergency call emergency
call get on this call I think he would
talk about you know mega experiment and
this experiment that he's doing and what
he's doing with this person that he
would get on the call and just like you
gotta have the right mindset like
talk about mindset for hours and these
calls are just like be Syria if you have
random calls I like to a.m. Eastern Time
and I'm there like falling asleep like
what is it this guy's not teaching me
what I need to know and love with with
them like he would make you feel bad
right because I don't know if you saw
the video that he posted on YouTube
we're like I was talking saying how good
the program was but he basically made us
get on camera on Billa and so he's like
say something good to say something that
you learn before we get in that let me
tell the viewers that was the worst
edited video I've ever seen in my life
but what was fascinating is that you did
see all these guys who later said the
course is bad saying good things so my
question is how did he get testimonials
from you guys before you had like really
finish the course
well that's the thing after every course
you would basically make everybody go
one by one and say what they learned
even if they didn't learn anything and
if we didn't do it you basically talked
down on us your mind says bad you're not
in this game you're not gonna be
successful and basically putting people
on the pedestal is not a pedestal put on
the spotlight like basically saying
you're a piece of [ __ ] if you don't say
something good that's exactly how it was
and you would ask every single person in
the u 90x they would attest to that so
but even in that video that he did add
it or whoever headed it you hear me say
I don't know if you caught it was
Barry's I thought yeah I saw you I saw
you I saw you in it but I was always
like I didn't learn anything still you
took material there was one little tiny
bit that I said and he actually put in
the video out on a why but you can't say
that funny material I need to find that
out fine fine all right so now you know
basically this point this this is sketch
and if it's real it's weird I mean I'd
like you don't you think it's probably
fake is it has it been 90 days or did
y'all revolt sort of early early because
there's like there's absolutely
impossible to get to 100 K with the
amount of time give blood right right so
yeah feel like another event had his
house and all these things were just
like for show you know there's really no
value in any
the stuff that he did except to show
like in this video we spent money on
this and this and that
why did you spend money on that why
didn't you spend money on something
that's gonna teach us and your coaches
cuz you can pay any of his coaches
instead of that buying you buying this
and you know going on yachts and doing
these trips why don't you use the money
on actual coaches and that's why I must
go left because you didn't pay Moscow
Moscow was supposed to be the top
Facebook guy that teaches everybody
Facebook well does he business guy pay
anyone anything not at all okay so he
takes in 500k of your money 10k roughly
10k from every person if we can make
takes in half a million dollars in one
shot for a 90 day course and doesn't
bother to pay a single coach to help you
guys get there he was he was in Bali he
was in Cabo he was taking private jets
that money's gone he used that money as
soon as you got it to take all the trips
okay so everyone starts sort of all
everyone says this guy's a scam and this
is when the Instagram stories come out
so for the viewers bob-dad how I found
him was Bhagyam starts posting a series
of Instagram stories where he's
basically starts to expose this guy and
starts to show screenshots and starts to
blow the lid on the whole thing and do
you want to tell that tell that real
quick like everything that happened yeah
sure I mean like it so it took a while
you know and I was always the only one
that spoke out there's always just me
and people were they were coming to kind
of coming at me like oh you're being
negative you need to just rush the
process and I was like there's no trust
in the process this is just [ __ ] and
people eventually started catching on
one by one that started going and
started believing me you know and they
started following me but for a long time
for a light 30 day like deal like 15 to
20 days it was just me like I don't care
like this is nonsense
this is not what we paid for I don't
know why you guys are stuff Lynda's and
he would still have calls and basically
having some of the students defend him
on the calls and what I learned actually
like two days ago was that he would have
a call with three or four people before
our resume hold training calls and he
would tell them be very positive about
the program keep telling people positive
that the programs doing really well and
he was also telling these people that
are my polar that's why he told off he
told her we're out on the people hustler
on Instagram
he told husk heard that I was bipolar
and that's why I was talking [ __ ] about
him
and puzzler told me cuz that's long ago
when did the tide shift when did
everyone read cuz it when I can't when I
realized about it like when I found out
about it everyone was on your side at
that point you were all you had
basically won the conversation and
people were like oh dude this guy this
guy's a straight-up scam when did that
when did that happen so all I believed I
was I wasn't really going hard at him
socially in social media but I was doing
it in private in the groups in our
groups and we head in there I think it
happened when Moscow decided to leave he
left Josh and and he joined our group so
we were talking to him and he's just
like yeah he doesn't say anything in the
groups make yo tell people privately and
I guess people start catching on to that
and then they start messaging me you
know one day it was like ten messages
and I was like oh okay like he scammed
these people let me just post this
screenshot of post a screenshot of
posted next day I'm waking up with like
50 to 100 messages and then the day
after that it was like almost a thousand
messages I was there seven eight hours a
day just on my phone replying messages
or posting screenshots just just of what
this guy's done to how many people like
and it wasn't even just a 90 X right
this guy like has a trail of he's been
doing it for a while on like all his
partners but his HTM courses you know
there were scamming people left them
right with that with his dropout degree
when he first started that they were
basically taking people's money and just
ghost in them basically with everything
they do it seems like they'll launch a
course they'll warn something they'll
take all the money for it they'll have
apply to people for a week or two and
then just go goes and just stop posting
stop lying to people so this is where it
gets tricky for me because this is now
we're almost caught up to date with like
now because John is Josh guy jet set fly
official maybe fake humor of the year I
don't know if we couldn't declare that
yeah but it's very possible he's a hot
contention for fake guru of the
year but uh he says something about
refunds cuz you're banging down the door
for I don't know like how many days or
weeks but you start like saying day you
better give me my money back and
everybody's saying that he says he's
gonna give Rieff do you think that's
true have you gotten a refund and what
it would tell me about that so he wants
people to sign our NDA non-disclosure
agreement and uh and I was like I was
like very sketched about that
there was one person that this sign that
had they actually got their money back
they invested 5k they got two payments
of twenty five hundred so they think
they did get refunded but I'm just like
if you have nothing to hide and if you
are doing proper business like you say
you are why should anybody have to sign
an NDA
you know it's damage control firm at
this point he's willing to pay up to
give to silence people I bet in the
person he really wants a sign that NDA
is you it's me I was the first person
you reached out to to try to get it to
sign him I was telling him no and like
I'm so on the fence because at this
point he's been so exposed and there's
been like really big names already
exposing them I'm like what more can I
really do right so I'm there like
telling them no I'm not sign that NBA
and then like a couple hours later I'm
like alright just send me the NDA and
then couple hours later I'm like nah
[ __ ] that I'm not signing this NDA I'm
like talk because I really want my money
back and there's so many people that are
messaging me and are still asking me for
help but at the same time I still need
my money cuz I still need my I need to
help myself you know a hundred percent
hey you know has anyone thought I'm
suing this guy I'm sure that's y'all's
first thought right like has anyone
approached the I'm suing this guy so
yeah I don't have to sign an NDA people
are definitely working on every side you
know the fans of starting something so
all right that's fair that's fair I
don't want to make you say spoil you
know spoil anything about about any any
kind of if there is or if there is not a
lawsuit or anything legal at all we'll
just keep that where it is but dude I
just want to make sure that this josh
guy this jet set fly fake guru net
scams anyone again and I have part of me
feels like okay it's out there it like
it's been so well documented and then
part of me thinks I'm afraid that the
Internet's gonna forget in like two
years
and this guy's gonna start posting again
and he still has those 275k followers
he's gonna get followers who who never
heard the bog damn tales you know who
had never heard I've never heard about
this and they're gonna go and they're
gonna fall for this guy's new course or
whatever and like how do you feel do you
think do you think that's gonna happen
or what what what have you taken away
from this it's not ever gonna be two
years it's gonna be two months because
people have short attention spans and
short memories I feel like you did lose
all this credibility at least maybe not
with the 270,000 followers but what
every single person that has any say or
any influence in the industry he lost
credibility no you're right and this
stuff this stuff does catch up with
these people but I wish it was a little
bit faster absolutely all right well
thanks for coming on the show man I
appreciate you I just wanted I saw a
rare moment to catalog a Syrian tin time
of like a fake guru in action somebody
who got really affected by his lie lies
promises and then eventually like the
aftermath of that and then the guy
getting like caught so much so that he
end up ends up admitting maybe not
apologizing but admitting that he you
know he messed up he screwed up so I
really thank you for giving blending
your experience dude this is crazy it's
gonna be a great addition I appreciate
your time preciate you coming on the
show absolutely thank you for having me
[Music]
[Music]
but never to the trust
[Music]